Speaker 1: And finally today,
speaking of serious trouble,
how do you feel about going to war in Mexico?
Not war with Mexico, folks. But Republicans
are warming up to the idea of using the
United States military to take on those
nasty drug cartels down in Mexico. Let me
read you this from Politico. In recent weeks,
Donald Trump has discussed sending special forces
and using cyber warfare to target cartel leaders.
If he's reelected president and Per Rolling Stone
asked for, quote, battle plans to strike Mexico.
Representatives Dan Crenshaw and Mike Waltz,
both Republicans, introduced a bill seeking
authorization for the use of military force to
put us at war with the cartels. Senator Tom Cart,
Tom Cotton of Arkansas, said he is open to sending
U.S. troops into Mexico to target drug lords, even
without that nation's permission. And lawmakers
in both chambers have filed legislation to label
some cartels as foreign terrorist organizations,
a move supported by GOP presidential aspirants.
So labeling drug cartels as terrorist
organizations basically gives the government
a lot more leeway to send in U.S. troops without,
of course, having to go through getting all that
authorization from Congress officially declaring
war. If we can just slap a broad label on them,
we can kind of kill whoever we want to kill.
And that is unfortunately, the way that our
government is set up in a post-9-11 world. Here's
the thing. This really isn't about the drugs.
It's not. Believe it or not, it's not
about the drugs. What this is about.
Is being able to bomb a sovereign nation, to
shoot whoever we want to shoot down in Mexico
by claiming they're a drug smuggler. Now imagine,
if you will, a caravan, let's call it a caravan
of people approaching our southern border.
And then folks on Fox News and Republican
politicians and candidates tell us we know a
lot of these people are are smuggling drugs.
Suddenly. You're able to apply that
terrorist label to these so-called caravans.
And you can send one missile. You send
a drone down there to take them out.
That's what this is about. It's not about
the drugs, folks. It is not about the drugs.
It is about getting that label so
that they can use the military force,
so that they can attack migrants, so that they
can attack asylum seekers all by claiming,
nope, they had drugs, they were
smuggling drugs. We'll never know,
right? I mean, we'll never be able to fully
find out if they did or didn't have drugs.
And that's the plan. That's what this is
about. This is about a show of force on
our southern border, not deep in Mexico, but on
our southern border, giving the United States,
the Republican Party the ability to kill anybody
that they don't want in this country. That's all
the time we have for today. But we've got a great
bonus show coming up for you. I am Farron Cousins
from Ring of Fire. Thank you so much for
watching today. I'll see you again tomorrow.